bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo numidio sono fra i geni oggi
giochiamo una roba molto singolare non
so se vi ricordate getting over
vabbè è una roba tipo giochiamo che
mentre siamo sulla iss action chiami di
sta roba purtroppo hanno fatto e stanno
facendo delle robe e che non io
iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi sono
l'unico che porta ancora ste cagate
negli anni io ho giocato a videogames
tanti tanti sul canale non ho ancora non
mi è ancora capitato di giocare una roba
da dove schiacci un tasto e ti sia lunga
che si allunga al naso c'erano giocata
robe simili ma si allungava
qualcos'altro che io ragazzi o questa
sottospecie di pinocchio pelato e molto
carino tra l'altro e devo l'obiettivo è
quello di stato o scriva toast e robben
non so come l'obiettivo è quello di
andare avanti nel gioco schivando le
belle cose
ecco non andando anche neanche nelle
buche perché in qualche modo esplodi non
so perché non so anche fisica ma non
andiamo nelle buche e non tocchiamo le
spine neanche le pale non tocchiamo una
sega però io allungo al mio naso
bellissimo spero che abbiano fatto anche
la versione di rocco siffredi visto
gioco ragazzi allora l'obiettivo è
quello di arrivare alla fine spero di
riuscire in questa mia mega impresa non
so quanto questo gioco possa essere
difficile però secondo me è uno di quei
rage game stupidi usa il naso non ho
letto usa al naso per lanciare le spine
cosa c'è scritto andando avanti nel
tempo sempre capito maggiormente che
cosa che fa girare le pelotas nei giochi
del genere
praticamente quando giochi a un rating
del genere la cosa che ti fa più
straziare le budella non è tanto il
fatto che mori e vabbè coloro si sa più
che altro ragazzi e che il gioco in sé è
talmente stupido che ti fa arrabbiare il
fatto che tu stia morendo in un gioco
stupido e questo fattore che aumenta la
rabbia del doppio praticamente questa
qua
alle spine non mi faceva niente bene
buono a sapersi anche getting over i
ragazzi ci pensate un gioco stupidissimo
è la cosa che ti fa ancora di più
arrabbiare oltre il gioco in sé è
proprio che un gioco stupido quindi
tutti stai arrabbiando per gioco stupido
eccolo il fatto quindi io con sta roba
qua più o meno porco il demonio morto mi
ci ritrovo quando gli si allunga al naso
tu vedi cose che prima non vedevi cioè
sta roba incredibile come se ci fossero
due mappe in una porca vacca se non
distrugga la tastiera oggi ragazzino ha
visto più allora angolari da che lì
iniziano questa discussione
l'inizio di un gioco o guarda c'è un
gioco tranquillo giocherà un ragazzo che
non posso giocare a rob e normali invece
io sta roba qua perché l'ho fatto mi
sembrava carino giocare nei panni di un
pinocchio fermati qua per favore ok usa
il naso per lanciare le cose e io posso
lanciare questi così qui va bene ma li
lancio via perché così non mi uccidono
ho capito ragazzi ci ho messo un'ora e
mezza per arrivare fin qua quindi per
favore non mi toccate fate schifo
e bene però dove rilanciati dalla da
parte opposta perché se di lancio di qua
io poi ci scontro queste cose ve lo dico
già che sarà un problema
ok
lì c'è la morte quindi devo schivare
fortissimo ma è lo schifo proprio lui è
un check point questo è princi poi c'è
point e un checkpoint cosa devo fare
aiuto
cosa devo fare parlami una stella c'è
una stella
la prendo non riesco a te comunque ho 24
anni ragazzi cioè non potrò fare lo
youtube era ancora per molto allora
ragazzi per ri arrivare qua ci ho messo
un'ora e mezza quindi magari se
riuscissimo a non morire non sarebbe
male però la vedo veramente difficile
il bello è che in tutto questo la fisica
di sto gioco non è neanche al massimo mi
farei provare veramente per saltare ci
metti un ora quindi è proprio anche
difficile fare tutto lo vorresti fare
molto bene
quella non l'avevo visto ma chi se ne
frega a posto allora adesso corro mi
sbatto della stella corro come un
puledro corri ma allora che dove vado
non vado vado dove dovrei andare no
aspetta fermo dove port col demonio ma
dove vorrei andare ma spiegami no
ragazzi non ha senso se vi prego vi
prego vi scongiuro vi prego fatemi
finire sto gioco vi prego
cosa devo fare più di così dove devo
andare non c'è un non c'è un traguardo
allora spiegami che cosa dovrei fare qua
con sa stella spiegamelo se io la prendo
diventa così e e muoio quindi non posso
prenderla
non posso andare nessuna parte muoio a
prescindere sono morto c'è proprio non
c'è modo di far nulla sono morto posso
provato la indietro che torno 2 thor non
c'è niente poi 5 con un sasso però il
sasso dove c'era la stella prima quindi
no come non posso farti gioca finito
così ma veramente mi prendi in giro e
save to sorella streif raramente ragazzi
non c'è modo di finire sul gioco si è
trasformato tutto
e muori e possono tornare indietro c'è
ma spiegami madama veramente morto lì
non ci vado a c'è scritto morte vabbè
però qua non ci posso fare niente sono
morte ovunque io vada sono morto ma
scusami ma veramente finito così ma
porca vacca potevate fare un finale un
po più degno maledizione io ci credo
pure ci credo ci sono mi sono impegnato
per tornare invece qua sotto immagino
che morì davvero world ma cos'è vado ma
non era il finale ma come quindi lì dove
c'era scritto morte sicura in realtà non
era morte sicura quindi devi fare tutto
il contrario che pensi a perché lui è
pinocchio dice le bugie
ho capito collegati puntini quindi
quando uno ti dice una cosa tu non la
devi credere vai dall'altra parte ma dai
ma non avevo capito e io ero convinto
fosse finito lì maledizione infatti così
corto soggiorno non è corposo scemo però
non avevo capito bene ok queste lo
scavalcate fortissimo molto buono è
andata di sotto l'altra però non vale se
mi uccide
vado avanti ho davanti bye bye bye bye
bye bye veloce veloce loach e scappa che
c'è un tizio il primate ucciso chi era
quel tizio vai pinocchio che il gioco
stupido però è veramente geniale come
cosa se ci pensi di fare il contrario di
quello che ti dice però allo stesso
tempo mi da un non so che di perché sto
vivendo la mia vita in questo modo
dove devo andare a 18 bene l'ho fatta
proprio lui congratula shaun hai vinto
grazie grazie mille ai adesso un pass
free per mentire quindi possono intuire
gratuitamente scade il 1 agosto del 2006
mi devo sbrigare prima che scada scusa
mi fa veramente del 2006 ma come per
questo gioco nel 2006
comunque è stato il gameplay più lungo
della mia vita incredibile comunque
ragazzi visto che si tratta questo di un
gioco incredibilmente serio direi di
passare al successivo gioco che reputo
essere uno dei più geniali e seri della
storia
ragazzi questo è un gioco molto
particolare io sono un lombrico bianco
ai suoi minerale nave già allora vi
spiego praticamente c'è praticamente un
tunnel nero nello spazio io sono un
lombrico spaziale che deve notare e
battere gli altri lombrichi spaziali che
stanno combattendo con con me arrivare
all'astronave madre ok l'astronave madre
che non ha riedifica da raggiungere
store aggiungo però sono ultimo quindi
sono morto eccolo eccolo china eccolo
sarà la strana ma della principessa è
nata hai vinto il gioco non è vero
perché la principessa nasce solo ed
esclusivamente se tu arini primo qui
devo battere gli altri ragazzi difficile
è un gioco che richiede skill però ci
prova pezzo di schifoso a ma io posso
posso gustarmi e non lo sapevo
col cappello quando il cappello si
illumina posso gustare la mia velocità
ragazzi che sta roba qua eh
la b b la bibbia degli youtuber non so
spiegarmelo
porca vacca sono incastrato nella vagina
aia di nava giannina dunque i viaggi
interstellari sono questo se voi vi
chiedete perché eseguite fa vj questo il
motivo
e comunque io continuo a portà sta roba
nonostante siano passati dieci anni
quindi io mi iscriverei voi non so voi
ma guarda lì che siamo arrivati
incredibile molto più veloce non riesco
ad arrivare primo ma se mi impegno ci
riesco cioè to make up mi sta veramente
concentrando io sono prima opera
veramente difficile mantenere risultato
tipo borghese dai eccolo dagli sono
primo stavolta veramente vinto
eccolo eccolo infatti sono dong e oltre
pensateci bene vi sia piaciuto ragazzi e
spero sia stato un video istruttivo
anche per quanto riguarda lo spazio come
fatto lo spazio se siete iscritti al
canale bravissimi continuate così
schiacciata anche alla campanellina vi
serve perché quando carico i video li
vedete che sta tentasse mi piace
commentare qui sotto cosa ne pensate di
questo splendido gioco e io vado a bing
around beh ragazzi
[Musica]